I know for certain
that something is wrong
with that individual
and that person
will do it again
and possibly even escalate
and move on to people.
So, my name
is Deanna Thompson
and you may know me
as Baudi Moovan
from Netflix's
Don't F**k with Cats.
For people like me,
you wanna figure things out,
you can't
just let things go.
You become almost obsessed.
Where it becomes like
a living and breathing thing
that you need
to get answers for.
So you have to be like
really careful
not to get too attached.
You also have to be
really careful
not to like accuse people
publicly.
Like,
that's really dangerous.
You can't start throwing
accusations out
against people
because you don't know
who's at the other end
of the keyboard
and you don't know
their mental state.
We do everything
like super private.
We don't post public
information
unless the person
has basically
been convicted
at that point.
We don't really
do that at all
because you just
have to be so careful.
We witnessed it first hand.
I've experienced
my own danger
with being a web sleuth
and even though
it was nothing,
it scared
the crap out of me.
And the danger would come in
a couple of different ways,
I think.
One is, the person or thing
that you're investigating
finds out that
you're investigating them.
And then they start
investigating you.
So like,
the tables are turned now
and everything
is now focused on you.
And that's a dangerous thing
because the people that are
doing these crimes,
most of the time,
they want attention.
And what better attention
to be like
"I'm killing these kittens…
how great would it be
if I killed the person
that's investigating me
killing these kittens.
I'll get a lot of press
for that."
But then another thing
that's dangerous
is getting
too invested in it.
You know, there's a quote
that Luka often sent to me.
Luka is the person
that we were looking at,
that was in the documentary
Don't F**k with Cats.
And I don't remember
the exact quote
and I'm sure you guys
can edit this
and look it up and put it on
the screen or something,
but it's the abyss quote
by Nietzsche,
it's the, you know "If you
stare too long at the abyss,
the abyss
stares back at you."
So he was like, recognising
that I was getting
too invested in finding him.
And would often tag me on
like a 4chan or 7chan post
and be like "Baudi Moovan,
the longer you stare
at the abyss,
the abyss stares
back at you."
And every time that happened
I would be like
fuck he's right.
I need to step away
for like a couple of day.
So that's another danger
that any web sleuth
can get into.
It's that they're just
so invested
in finding this person
that they lose all sense
of reality around them.
That's a dangerous
thing to do
and your mental health
is too important to do that.
I've had to go to therapy…
because of this work.
And there's a lot of guilt
that comes with this work
because you want to be able
to prevent the next one,
but then
the next one happens
because you didn't find out
the information in time.
And there's also
a lot of like:
'Oh god, humanity is so
gross', you know.
Like we are so gross,
why are we doing this?
So, I had to go to therapy
and it's out
of my own pocket.
I have to pay for this.
So it's not like I have
a professional
network to rely on,
you know, like people in
law-enforcement would.
The first thing
I would tell the people
that are interested
in web sleuthing
is you can't be emotional.
So, if you're
an emotional person
this is not gonna be…
a good area
for you to go down.
When you're
an emotional person,
I'm an emotional person
so I know this,
when you're
an emotional person,
your anger and your rage
over the things
that you're investigating
sometimes
cloud your judgement.
So I've learnt to kind of…
and just look at the facts.
D'you know what I mean?
And the more
you look at the facts,
the more you get enraged
and the more
you have to calm down.
So being an emotional person
is a bad thing.
So, if you're
an emotional person
you really have to learn how
to tame your emotions.
You don't wanna add
to the noise.
The second thing I would do
is go join the web sleuth's
website and just observe.
Don't participate,
just observe.
I learned so much
by just watching.
Sometimes just watching
you'll get more knowledge
than actually participating.
So you don't always
have to have a voice,
you just sometimes
have to listen.
The third thing I would
tell somebody is
don't be afraid
of technology.
Technology is sometimes
this big, scary Org
that people are like afraid
to like look in,
like, how do I figure out
where this email
actually came from?
People are afraid to like,
use tools to figure out,
you know,
those answers
and I would say
don't be afraid
of technology.